we also have an update to a story we
shared in March about highway barriers
families of car crash victims are
expected to file wrongful death lawsuits
today against a company that makes those
guardrails their attorneys claimed seven
people nationwide have died in accidents
involving these x-lite guardrail end
pieces made by the Lindsay corporation
dashcam video shows Wilbert birds deadly
crash the guard will apparently pierced
the car instead of retracting as it's
designed to do and we spoke yesterday to
the parents of accident victim Lauren
Beutel absolutely 100% feel that she
would still be alive if that guardrail
end piece had not been in place because
it acted like a skewer and went through
the car and it wasn't supposed to do
that it was supposed to protect them now
the Lindsay corporation tells CBS News
in a statement X Light has successfully
passed crash and safety tests in
accordance with federal standards and
criteria and remains qualified for use
on America's roadways